you know we both did our time at starnet
live you of course uh with much more
distinction and fame than i did i don't
know that's true
listen i realized that going i mean you
i i was a cast member you wrote for it
and you watched it and uh
uh i mean i used to
no but it is amazing that those i had a
one-year contract
and i and i i kind of regret it
i wish i'd because it made me nervous so
nervous
every every saturday was like a special
and i felt i only
i really i thought i mean you would put
so much work and not just you a couple
of your cohorts would put so many words
it was christopher guest yes and you
would craft these things these pieces
you came up with a character that uh i
remember when this
character first appeared and it was
seared into everybody's memory anyone
who's interested in comedy
you would create these things that were
so memorable nathan thurm
one of the great for my money one of the
great comedy characters of all time and
i was i remembered at the time thinking
how do you come up with a character like
that it was so incredibly original
yeah well i i've told the story before
and i'll tell it again
um but it was amazing because i always
think the characters the best characters
come
from life you know you you pick up your
cleaning
and the guy said i couldn't get the
thing out mr short time
now he's not trying to be a character
from sergeant live but he is he's uh
dressed pants and um so there was a
a makeup artist that year in snl marion
seibert
and she was the most defensive human
being
you had ever met in your life you'd sit
in her chair
and she'd always chain smoke you could
do that inside and anymore
and she dab look at me
your features don't match this is tough
for me
you're very pale yeah
so um i'd say uh okay well that's fine
so then about a month later christopher
gastner harry sure
and billy and i were writing a piece
satirizing 60 minutes
and i was going to play the defensive
lawyer the lawyer who always represents
the bad guy knows
and we even had a name from nathan thurm
but i didn't know how to do it i didn't
know how to play it
and billy crystal said why don't you do
it as marion seibert
he said you do her behind her back all
the time anyway
and i said no no i'll be caught i'll be
kind of
she won't no they never know so i'd go
down
to the set i got the same brand of
cigarettes that she smoked
i but i put a wire down the middle of
mine so as the burn down the ash would
never fall off
yes and i go down to the set but i
forget
that marion will be there because she's
the head of makeup
so we start the take i'm nathan thurm
she's over there we both have our
cigarettes harry's playing mike wallace
he's mr
now mr thurm do you feel that was an
appropriate behavior for a lawyer and i
say i know that
you don't think i know that i'm a lawyer
i would know that and the director goes
cut he's sweating and marion says i know
that you don't think i know that i'm a
[ __ ]
it was insane and then then every time i
did nathan turner i was terrified
i would get caught and i never got
caught until the last
show um her assistant got there was a
big party after her assistant got drunk
and went into her office said marion
do you know that you're nathan's therm
oh everybody else does
and she was devastated she was so upset
she confronted me
at the party and she said i thought you
were my friend
i said marion i am your friend but you
know
impersonation is the highest form of
compliment she said i know that you
don't think i know
true story this is all true it's jack
far with this whole crew
threw a little nixon in there for no
reason yeah and by the way courting the
kids with that
kids love my stuff
[Music]
thank you two people uh they're going
right into their phones
nixon what did he do